mais je sais dit que c'est plus du fait
de jeu le français du tout jeune je
branche est classé britannique nous
paraissent que le chat ne reçoit plus
tôt fromelles où je suis avec du blues
et shota longue haleine à temps quand la
mariée jaloux
au jeune homme
je m'achète dans la boue je je
quand le médecin qui me collait des
bantous jeu
les shadoks laisse croire qu'on prend
les français pour des pauvres dégénéré
manteau spectateurs interprète de
beaucoup d'autres je constate très
amèrement le peu de considération que
les responsables de vos services en pour
le public à faire
en effet non seulement ce bon public
aura été privé l'émission au cours de
mai et se verra contraint de régler les
redevances annuelles
grasset ben voyons
quand la manier jalouse
quand je m'achète dans l'âme
aux jeunes je viens
dans le match mais bon tout je joue
chatel
les shadoks que signifie ce mot tout via
t-il je n'ai pas trouvé dans le lard et
où il était
faut-il conclure que les auteurs
s'ingénie abêtir les auditeurs français
et qu'il souhaiterait donner l'exemple
de la marche des français vers les
établissements psychiatriques où l'on
affiche très complet pour les français
défi au bon sens français ça monsieur
les shadoks passe après le journal
télévisé monsieur ben voyons la blouse
faut pas croire que c'est seulement pour
les grades la nouvelle orléans
je prends mon corps - qui suit mérigeau
je connais le blues aussi bien que mes
cochons
car pour ce qui est des grands
sentiments dans le monde entier c'est
nous pas les
notre positive pour une fois qu'un
français
j'espère que vous êtes français monsieur
fait un dessin animé excellent full of
spirit plein d'esprit en anglais d'un
humour français digne d'être britannique
calicots - prix jules perfide albion